it's one thing to be seen it's another
thing to be seen for what are you being
seen because you know how to kick a
football past a goalie
are you being seen because you're wildly
attractive are you being seen because
you're funny are you being seen because
you stole money and it looks like you've
made money like what are you being seen
for I want to be seen more than anybody
in the world why I'm being seen is what
I'm most proud of you got your
perspective
[Applause]
[Music]
YouTube what's up so so grateful that
you clicked and you're about to watch a
new youtube video but before you do - 1
2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 that is my texting
community platform doing a lot of
one-on-one engagement in there and also
access opportunity first looks in that
environment
- 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 join it now and now
to the video you've been wanting to
watch yes sir very good you got it like
that I swear yes we more than me but I
want you to be happy to do it
I'm a very grateful human and that
gratitude drives a lot of functions of
my life the way I the way I build
businesses the reason that I'm even
doing this interview ok people know who
I am
at its core I'm a deeply grateful
individual who you know for context you
know was an immigrant from the Soviet
Union who went to the US and like many
immigrants in many parts of the world
had the luxury of the adversity of that
situation become foundational which also
led to a complete lack of entitlement
which leads to humility but deep drive
and conviction while parented very well
parented and deeply ambitious you know
deeply ambitious for legacy first and
and that's that's who I think I am
to talk about but first one is your
childhood yes yes yes I think it shaped
me a lot you know I I think that not
having a lot at a young age is a very
big advantage you know it's very hard to
be hungry when you've been fed and so I
think it shipped me in a lot of ways a
I'm extremely close to my mother like
very close be you know not only did we
not grow up with a lot but on top of not
growing up with a lot my mom is deeply
cheap so even when we it's crazy even we
got to like middle-class we still lived
in like I you know it's fun to like
think about you know as I've gotten more
notoriety and as I've challenged myself
to bring more value to people I've had
to think a lot more about what's worked
and and then you just start thinking and
I'm like wait a minute you know things
that I never thought feeling like wait a
minute after a while we were not that
poor but we still didn't buy anything oh
crap my mom's cheap you know it is well
my mother my mother my mother was dad my
grandfather kind of you know in
communism you're not allowed to really
own anything but it was all black market
and he kind of you know clearly I've got
my both my grandfather's had a lot of
entrepreneurial DNA so it makes a lot of
sense of Who I am
she kind of was like pretty well-off
which by the way in Belarus in the 1950s
and 60s was ghetto but it was the but
she was the ghetto queen of the ghettos
and then my grandfather went to jail for
ten years in communist and Russia and
she lost everything and I think that has
always stuck with her her having a
little something in context and her
losing that she but we talked about it
last week like you know I'm trying to
get my parents I'm concurring them
they're thinking about buying a home in
Miami to
down you know they're getting older
nurse you know mid 60's they're starting
to I want them to enjoy this next decade
and she's a cheap girl from the old
country
she really is I need to have this much I
got to feel like and for me it's a
little different but the same I don't
have a number I need to have but I save
money which is like something nobody
talks about anymore
I don't ones like how do I raise money
nobody talks about saving money you know
and so yes more than solid I I would
argue that I fear the death of my
parents at the same level that I fear
the death of my children which i think
is unnatural which speaks to the
relationship I think I have with my
parents I'm not
right yes we can criticize it so much me
anymore because I'm the same when I
talked about it but what do you think is
really maybe quick change that we can do
to it at least start being in the right
path I think we have to understand that
every single human is different and if
we don't reverse engineer what they're
good or bad at and they have to go
through one singular system it's
inconceivable that we're doing anything
good for them miraculously 33% of those
kids 18 29 54 71 will get what they want
I just think that it's unfortunate to
force somebody from six to 18 or 22 to
go through a system that doesn't brings
them no value and prepares them for
nothing that happens in real life
how are we still in 2020 in a world
where we do not educate children on how
to manage money like not a kid is being
taught about how to manage money every
kid is being talked about outer space
who gives a [ __ ] about outer space I
don't care about Saturn people don't
know how to pay their taxes we it's a
complete a it doesn't work for everybody
and it and everyone has to do it that's
bad be looking at the room here and
definitely the people behind the camera
anybody who now lives life post-school
realizes there's an enormous amount
about life that we were not prepared for
in any shape or form why one size fits
all can't work for anything to even
what's taught in there is missing core
things why don't we teach self-esteem
why don't we teach money management why
don't we teach
any why don't we teach anything that's
valuable let's everything that's taught
is stuff that people memorize why should
i memorize something I'll give me
where's my phone I got the answer my
phone it's great the whole system is
fundamentally broken what they talk
about is how you need your fingerprint
is how unique is a person and how
special you are right but then all the
big systems are one-size-fits-all
education all of you have to have a
bachelor's degree yeah but I don't want
to say you have to pass biology I don't
like well you may have to but you said
I'm special you said I'm unique I don't
want no you have to so suddenly if you
don't even have a CV who looks at you
today very few corporations who wants to
work for a corporation but you see what
I mean but by the way the best
corporations in the world are not
looking at CVS anymore College will
quote Google face these are not College
required companies vaynermedia proudly
does not yeah but listen a lot of things
take so long like we it took us so long
to demonize beating your wife it took us
in America in 1975 in America in 1975
half the states it was legal to rape
your own wife it take us so long for
everything it
we had concentration camps that murdered
millions of Jews 70 years ago we do a
lot of things that are stupid people are
very funny they're the best but we have
tons of stupid things and the modern
education system in an Internet world
makes no sense
[Music]
I'm like [ __ ] that's refreshing
because I hear all the fluff on the
other side all of these life coaches
sending so many words giving that
24-hour boost of morale which then
crashes and I'm like okay at least this
guy is real the question I have which is
also related to what you just said in
the time when we have the Internet me
and you 13:44 we didn't have internet in
the beginning today they have every tool
every search to not fail why do you
think so many entrepreneurs do cuz it's
hard it's hard
this is entrepreneurship got cool look
at you and I look at you and I right now
dressed and acting at 38 and 44 when we
were 6 and 7 years old people at 38 did
not wear the Travie scots nike like you
know like like it's a different culture
and but it's hard it's hard number to
entrepreneurship got cool and that's the
biggest issue right now it's trending
people like like you know it's crazy
like I'm a 40 I'm the coolest I've ever
been at 44 because entrepreneurship got
cool and now everybody wants to be one
just like a rapper just like an athlete
it's that cool that's dangerous because
first of all every guy wants to do it
because it helps them get girls 90% of
them should not be entrepreneurship
entrepreneurship is super lonely it's
anxiety filled I was telling d-roc
yesterday I hate being on this part of
the world because when we go to sleep
there's still action going on in New
York and New York is where most of my
headaches are and I can't attend to it
so I go to sleep not as comfortably it's
lonely right
I mean I wake up at 3:00 a.m. right the
note that I saw I just don't forget a
minute it's not end right now people
raise capital so they can make pretend
they're winning
when you raise capital you can disguise
correct so I'm talking about it not
because I want to say I'm an
entrepreneur and you're not I'm saying
it because I know what happens next what
happens next is the money stops flowing
because there's a global economic
slowdown and I do believe that 90% 95%
of the people that we know that have
startups will fail because they didn't
build a business they were building a
deck to raise more capital completely
the run in for the game they're in it
for what how it makes them look and the
potential of money just because what why
are you doing it so you have to have
passion but you have to have the skill
for it
do something you're better than nobody
actually good at or if you have the
passion and your skill is okay settle
into knowing that you're only gonna make
one hundred thirty thousand aim for
happiness be self-aware I'm not the best
fashion designer but I love it so much
that I know I'm not gonna make five
million a year but I love it so much
right nobody's talking about that yes
it's you know I mean like look this is
real for me I want to make the hundred
thirty thousand dollar take home fashion
designer happy the problem is right now
every fashion designer wants to become
off-white they are like if it's not a
there are kids running around thinking
that if they don't build a billion
dollar company it's not a big company
we've completely lost sense of reality
it's complete
the broken one thing to to compliment
over saying is I read I've done a bit of
research
thanks to Nikki that you at one point
we're posting I think of you every day
on YouTube for years correct yes and
this I think what people don't realize
is the hard work the focus the
consistency the quality
thank you what you weren't able to
research was from 2007-2011 I replied to
every single email and tweet I got until
four in the morning
nobody knew who I was so I would go into
Twitter search search whine terms and
jump into conversations that people
would tweet having this Pinot Noir and I
would reply they didn't know me and I
would reply that's a good one did you
try the year before and slowly but
surely for hours and hours and hours for
years and years and years I built a
foundation that years and years and
years later started the creation of what
people see now and meanwhile people
start a tick tock account post five
times don't go viral and they're like
this sucks I know what the issue is
people are relationships which will
briefly talk about as soon as they don't
have to pay my pocket yeah
it's so sweet gratification that I'm not
even wired to just [ __ ] wait or I go
to the gym they go three times in I
don't have a six-pack but it's scary
that nobody's giving that what I was
asking you about the consistency of
effort you know you're preaching the the
lost art of patience and foundational
and and this has a lot to do with
parenting our parents generation around
the world where they could when they
they borrowed money from parents our
parents borrowed money from grandparents
and paid them back if they wanted a
house or start a business now kids think
their parents should just give them
money if you're 22 years old or older in
the world and your parents are giving
you money you're in deep trouble because
you have been told by your parents and
you've told yourself that you were
incapable of standing on your own two
feet which immediately leads to
insecurity which leads to very bad
behavior the end and then when I say
this this may be the fifth or sixth time
I've said this publicly I'll get a bunch
of emails saying you don't know me I
have two children from a bad man who
left them like live in a worse house I'm
like why am I looking at you're in your
situation so horrible and you need to
think your appearance why did I just
click your Instagram account and you
have a Prada bag we've become so
materialistic that people want all these
things but they want them the question
is why do they want that they want them
because we're communicating to the world
every one of us right now is wearing
what we're wearing our haircuts
everything communication we're
positioning ourselves to the world
I really really think there's a lot of
important conversations that are not
being had I'm trying to throw them out
there and I enjoy I remember you know
meeting with you like a year ago like I
like when people see what and and my
hope is that if I have the courage to
say stuff that people aren't talking
about then others will start doing it
like these are important this is an
important video this what if one kid or
grown up watches this on YouTube and
changes their behavior that's intense
legacy thousands and eventually it
becomes the culture this is the first
year that I've seen kids and cool kids
post under Instagram things like
gratitude and empathy and kindness and
I'm like I'm making an impact you know
yes
[Music]
yes it's easy to sustain relationships
today you know we're talking about other
people that quit how do you survive I
don't want even use the word survivors I
think it has a negative connotation how
do you sustain a healthy relationship
with all that attention every
relationship whether it's your spouse
your boyfriend/girlfriend your children
your parents your business partners your
siblings every relationship is 100%
predicated on communication and that's
it and when it works for me it works
because communication and when it
doesn't work for me it's because of
break down to communication and and
that's it that's for me and that's for
every other single person on earth it's
that it's kind of like everything else
we talk about I think one of the things
that's been obvious to me in our limited
interactions with each other is I don't
think we overthink things you made a
great point about plastic surgery I
think about that a lot I really do when
I talk about business or how simple I
just answered the relationship question
all of this is wildly simple people just
don't want to do it you want to you want
your body to look better eat better and
go to the gym that's it that's it every
course every book every conference every
video is just extra layers of fat on a
very simple thing you want to build a
business here's how you do it
make something that people want make it
always about the customer make it always
about your employees be patient be
disciplined
rinse and repeat rinse it you know these
things can be wildly simple the problem
is we complicate them more importantly
the things that are simple are actually
hard it's hard yeah it's hard to do hard
work if you know people have egos like
you know I tell the kids all the time at
27 years old I was in a liquor store in
New Jersey ringing people up and taking
boxes to the car that's my life that's
why I was doing that so of course when
you're 24 and you're freaked out that
you haven't made it yet
of course I'm gonna laugh at that of
course I lived something else I I want
you to see it so I think it's
communication of course I think I'm the
most public I'm the most public private
person there is easy likes yeah you know
what gets easy likes girlfriends and
boyfriends your pet children lay up I am
convinced that there are enormous
amounts of people in the world that have
children just for Instagram now that
doesn't bother me believe it or not
because I believe an enormous amount of
people have children because they think
they're supposed to at a certain age
because their mothers putting pressure
on them like there's a lot of other
reasons people you know of course listen
one of the one of the reasons I think I
do resonate quite a bit in Asia in the
Middle East in other parts of the world
is I deeply understand immigrant culture
I deeply and and I understand old-world
culture 100 set an old world culture you
know like so I get it I get it I mean
the biggest one in the region for me the
single biggest reason I love coming to
this region is just to go on stage and
put pressure on the parents to stop
using their children as collateral for
their own ego the number one flaw the
one thing that Americans are detached
from their children which I don't think
is great but the one thing that is
extreme in this part of the world is
parents tell kids to do things that
makes them look good not makes their
it's a hundred percent selfish this this
part
the world Asia India wildly selfish
parents who forced their kids because it
makes you don't want to embarrass the
family you don't want it you want you
you have to go to that school to make me
look good you have to be an engineer or
a banker or you have to go to Harvard in
America to make me look good
I haven't even paid attention to what
makes you happy you're a product of me
and you know what makes me mad and I
talked to some of these 63 year-olds 45
year olds I'm like like this one hurts
me about 20 the cliche 22 year old kid
in this part of the world they listen to
their parents talk about how their
grandparents made them miserable for
doing what they wanted and they're just
repeating the same behavior of course it
is but it's but it's time for it to stop
and things stop when people start
talking and the reason I'm saying this
right now is for that reason hopefully
the next person takes it and it didn't
start with me these things were things I
heard or observe who the hell you know
you know sometimes you don't know where
you got it from but it's happening and
actually a lot of what works for me and
this might help others I think so much
of who I become has to do with my
listening not my talking I read comments
DMS emails that's how I learned people
tell me things it's really interesting
being a bother I'll explain why I am so
in love with my children yet I am so
passionate to not impose anything on
them
release the no of attractions it saw
last week recommended video click on it
Will Smith talks about how willow his
daughter was the challenge of his life
because he wants to impose things
because we do that like I said to Pete
are equal to enforce things on her and
he's like I realized that our kids are
like seeds the seed would be what it
would be whatever plan they may be us as
parents
shut up water 100 percent my daughter is
already showing that she is a remarkable
student she might be the best student in
class in a private school in New York
my daughter's much better at school at
this if my daughter is a much better
reader right now than I ever was
she and like that makes me happy like
when sometimes my friends figure this
out they're like are you okay I'm like
with what they're like you hate school
I'm like I hate school for me I love
school for her she's learning her ass
off I don't have any absolutes
I just want flexibility I don't have
absolutes
even though I speak in absolute terms
everybody else has absolutes right I'm
only gray I'm just talking about things
that are the alternative to the accepted
black got it that's what I doing
it can't it's you know why we're logical
it's been yeah but that but but by the
way that's how you know that's how we
got to this it can't one-size-fits-all
here's the proof
here's me not and I can show you a
million people that are happy functional
and wildly successful that crushed
school and loved it and that's amazing
but you know it's interesting I grew up
in the u.s. when entrepreneurship was
nothing and school was them and so now
to see if they reverse that it's funny
that's why I'm pushing against
entrepreneurship for everyone
I just want self-awareness individual
individual him him him him hurt her
individual what makes you happy what are
you good at
and then more you said something very
smart and and I added something but I
think we should go back to it if you
love something and you're good at it
it's going to be a big win I think the
nuance on that is if you love something
and you're not good at it it might be
worth doing cuz being happy is more
important than making money but you have
to be honest with yourself that you're
only gonna make a forty thousand dollars
a year being a painter because nobody's
gonna buy your painting if you learn to
live on a $40,000 a year budget this is
what you know what's funny I've realized
something about me I'm like right I'm
cooking an entire meal with the things I
talk about so in individual ingredients
when people look at it it might be one
thing but if you take all the things I'm
saying it's an entire meal okay and and
I like how you reacted I like that I
like it too because I think it can bring
a lot of happiness and if you understand
how the internet works there's a lot of
people that can be much happier if they
settle into I'm a sixty three thousand
dollar-a-year t-shirt maker you see
where I'm going but it takes another
ingredient and I know this is a good one
because I'm really getting them right
now you have to live a life on the means
of sixty three thousand you can't be a
sixty three thousand dollar-a-year
t-shirt guy but mommy and daddy are you
a hundred thousand a year so that you
can live in a better neighborhood and
drive a BMW cuz that's gonna lead to
resentment between mom and dad and you
and entitlement from you you have to if
you want to be a big-shot I love when
people you know some of my more young
liberal friends like I just want to be
happy and I'm like no you want to just
do art but you want your parents to pay
for it
we need more real conversations we have
to put making sixty three thousand a
year because you love t-shirts and
that's all you can do on Shopify and at
the flea market you have to buy a home
that you can afford you have to go to
the Holiday Inn not the ritz-carlton if
we can get to that it could get big it
could get real big and the way we do
that is by us applauding our friends who
make 63,000 and go holiday and not row
look I went to the ritz-carlton
an economy with my kids and I took a
picture then I posted it on the story
and he goes honest I don't get you
excuse me goes one day you're in a
private jet rather they are in first
class now you're in my car so when I'm
an economy I'm not supposed to post
that's what you're telling me bro it
doesn't matter I'm with my family I'm
happy doesn't change the fact that I
have to uh no I have to run off to first
nice because I've become but that's the
world not the world I live in
leave it me but I guess it's gonna
become the comment cuz this is gonna
break there's so much unhappiness in the
world it's not sustainable
[Music]
no I feel like I have so much time okay
I'm definitely not angry people confuse
how one communicates in a certain
environment for their truth when I'm on
stage talking to five thousand people
and I'm hyped and and if I'm angry I'm
angry at the systems that have created
their unhappiness I'm actually thrilled
that I escaped those vulnerabilities I'm
actually so grateful it's funny so I see
all those comments and Adderall the
funniest one is my college friends spent
their entire four years trying to get me
to smoke weed and I promised my mom in
seventh grade that I would never do
drugs so when people leave the comment
like adderall or cocaine because I'm so
fast and hyper meet my Hut my college
friends get the biggest kick cuz they
just think it's so funny because they're
like man if they just knew I'm fast but
that's just cuz I have a lot of
adrenaline and I talk fast like and my
brain works fast
[Music]
no I but I think I have enormous
confidence I think ego is insecurity I I
actually have no connection towards ego
I don't think I'm special let's just
start there I understand that I was
gifted things but that's not me I think
my parents are special I think my
parents should have an ego
but I'm the but I'm the byproduct how
the hell that's like I love people that
are gorgeous
they're funny to me you didn't do
anything and that's how I feel just
because I understand people better than
almost anybody I've ever met I didn't do
that that's my parents had sex at the
right second it's hard I mean this it's
hard for me to think I'm special or you
know I'd consume nothing that I put out
no I do not lately sing to myself at all
I like what I'm saying
that I that it took me a very long thing
I don't like about me is the thing I'm
most working on which is on a one-to-one
level I struggle with candor because I
don't like hurting people's feelings
which blows people away when I answer
that because I haven't shared that a lot
I'm starting to share it because I'm so
raw and real on stage but in real life
for my company and my relationships I
struggled with candor
because I hate negativity no worst
moment in my life
probably when I probably when I realized
there was real conflict between me and
my dad when I kind of really knew there
was one day when I left this store just
left it which I never did in November
when I was like 28 29 and I knew I knew
that I wouldn't be there anymore that
was tough for me because I really
enjoyed building that business for him
and I was willing to do it immigrant
style and be there for a very long time
I'm so patient that I thought I can do
this and build this for him into I'm 50
and then I'll go build my own thing
so that that hurt because I there was
more that I wanted to give him yeah
that's just something I've never really
said I've never said this out loud
ever but it's the true answer it was
tough because I felt bad for him know
that he let me get away when my daughter
was born I it's a very close one too
it's either the day my book my second my
daughter was born I looked at her I was
an aside she came out she was looking
straight and then she turned and looked
at me it's I've never ever cried so on a
second and so hard it was crazy yeah it
was guys it was super crazy I just I'm
so grateful it's so funny how I have
nothing close to that with my son sorry
Xander but she came out and I was right
here and when she turned I just it
completely destroyed me and that is
either one or it's two or it's tied with
the day that the New York Jets beat the
Patriots in New England in the second
round of the playoffs in 2011 I I I'm
not kidding the one place that I'm
completely irrational
because I'm not in control is my deep
love for the New York Jets the amount of
pain the Patriots had brought they had
beaten the Jets 45 2 3 5 weeks earlier
it was the playoffs all my friends that
usually come to jet games with me didn't
go just me and my brother and two other
people because they didn't want to go
there and get slaughtered I walked in
there like I was gonna get killed like
literally like this is I'm not I'm gonna
use the analogy but I was walking into
death I remember walking into that
stadium everyone's making fun of us not
a word no face and to watch them be able
to beat them and see that and then watch
all those Patriot fans have to leave and
this one guy was giving me a really hard
time five rows in front of me like he
was drunk he was nasty
you're gonna lose like spitting almost
fighting and then when they when it
became obvious the Jets we're gonna win
he tried to leave I'll never forget this
the Jets went up 10 points late the game
was over and he tried to leave and I was
like six seats in off the aisle the most
athletic thing I've done in my life I
somehow in one second went over six
people and grabbed him and said what a
[ __ ] do you think you're going and it
was like one of the great moments of my
life
maybe the best moment of my life I loved
the journey
I loved the journey you know what's
funny
I will actually argue that one of the
great vulnerability one of things I
don't like about Gary is I'm incapable
of smelling the roses I don't like the
win I didn't like my birthday the other
the team I had a really interesting
moment two weeks ago the team did
something very sweet for me my team Gary
put made content and put up my face and
a big thing for me in Times Square and
they brought me into an office and like
we got to show you something and d-roc
and D Kirk were in Times Square during
the hour and were live for me to see it
and I reacted as if they like stole my
wallet
and a lot of the team doesn't know me
that well and I remember thinking this
sucks
because
was so sweet and I'm so grateful but I
mean capable of faking my emotions so I
just I don't like you understand
it's a vulnerability of mine I actually
you know what's funny I'm satisfied you
know it's funny I'm fully satisfied and
again I'm fully satisfied right now when
I win I don't like it I don't like it I
just like the game it's why I think I'm
such a good entrepreneur I don't want
the money I don't want the BMW I don't
know I mean I'll try but BMW it's fine I
don't have one but like no none of this
is for this stuff all of it is for where
do I rank as the best entrepreneurs of
all time number 37 number 4 billion
number one number 19 like I'm playing
the game
the real game and I think actually one
of the reasons that I think I've become
the entrepreneur that is giving back by
far the most in my opinion to other
entrepreneurs with no is because I
probably subconsciously think that's my
hack to being the best entrepreneur
because Bezos and some of these other
then put up some real numbers and I
don't think I'm gonna get there but in
my own mind if I'm judging
entrepreneurship on impact I genuinely
think I'm having a huge impact on the
next generation of entrepreneurs and
that makes me proud and whether wherever
that means in ranking it feels very good
it makes sense yes yes yes this is the
feedback of admiration I'm chasing
admiration everybody out here is chasing
private jets I'm chasing admiration it's
one thing to be seen it's another thing
to be seen for what are you being seen
because you know how to kick a football
past a goalie are you being seen because
you're wildly attractive are you being
seen because you're funny are you being
seen because you stole money and it
looks like you've made money like what
are you being seen for I want to be seen
more than anybody in the world why I'm
being seen is what I'm most proud of
snakes don't like snakes so much yes
make some [ __ ] up you know I don't
like snakes I feared the death of 10 or
11 people a lot I actually think the
first time I truly disappear for a
little while it's probably one of my
parents death I can see myself really
going into a form of depression or a
funk because I lived my complete life on
the gratitude that those people are
healthy and happy
I'm completely pocket the reason I'm
fearless and happy is because it's about
those 12 people so my fear intuition
it's really the one thing left for me at
44 there's one thing left that I'm
curious about with me which is when I
lose one of them what happens do I do
what I normally do which is default into
such optimism that I say I'm so lucky
that I had all this time with them or
have I put all my chips in there and
when one of them goes I do go into a
place where I can't
get my juices going for a month three
months a year I don't know that answer
but that is the one thing left that I
want to that I'm excited I mean it I
make even though I fear it it's the one
thing that I'm it's the last piece of
curiosity I have about me because
everything else is very obvious you know
what's funny I'm I'm really good at not
regretting things but I will say this I
do believe that I took it too far when
it comes to work ethic between 14 and 30
I worked every minute nobody will ever
know my my mom got emotional about it a
couple years ago she's like they'll
never believe you because she almost
feels bad my dad too I mean I worked
every minute all of them well I mean all
of them literally every weekend every
summer vacation of my entire adolescence
I worked and I don't think that's
healthy that's too much that's I could
have used some balance
so I do regret that a little bit I do my
problem is it's hard for me to Greg ret
because I think me being so unique has
led to so much happiness that I the
reason I'm trying to challenge myself to
actually answer these questions with
that but but then I have to say this for
the record
and then even as I just told you that I
in my chemicals I can feel like no I
don't regret it because the extreme that
I went through created a very unique
voice that leads to all my happiness I I
can't I can't
it's my journey I can't I'm too happy
I'm just deeply happy and grateful I
can't critique
Gary
that's really good Gary in one word kind
[Music]
you